oui
[Musique]
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bonjour donc première question pourquoi
est ce que c'est important pour vous de
participer à la conférence de moscou sur
la sécurité internationale
d'abord je commence je commence par
remercier votre chaîne m'avoir
invité à m'exprimer on marche de cette
conférence de l'inflation dans le monde
pourquoi est un homme aux secours pour
passe pas cette activité vous savez la
riche est un pays ami
la réussite d'un bon nombre d'occasions
qu'on s'est situé à son jury l'a réussi
pèse beaucoup la sécurité internationale
et elle a montré depuis toujours et
surtout après la deuxième guerre
mondiale
donc ces mêmes l'intitulé de la réunion
qui fait qu' on vienne pour écouter
parce que c'est un moment des changes
parce que la paix n'est pas garanti la
sécurité c'est notre bien éternel
quand on en sécurité on peut aller
revenir on peut travailler un peu des
bressans pays ont facilement cip est soi
même
c'est pourquoi participer à cette
conférence
c'est venu échanger avec les autres pour
connaître les cas du monde aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on doit faire demain parce que
les défis sont importants
et qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous a paru
le plus important donc lors de cette
conférence vous avez parlé des échanges
avec d'autres pays avec les imagine avec
les autorités russes également
donc qu'est-ce qui vous a paru surtout
intéressant lors de cette conférence
parce que tu as termine aujourd'hui
c'est bien perdu 1 pendant le set quand
on sait le fait que la russie et on en
paie son leadership en matière de lutte
internationale et que beaucoup de pays
au cours de cet échange beaucoup d'eux
sourit jean est de clairement exprimé
leur préoccupation quant à la venue le
monde
quand le face à tous les défis
d'aujourd'hui le terrorisme la sécurité
maritime
les déplacements de population et
surtout je ne continuerais lui dire le
fait que la paix il n'est pas
nous sommes bien garanti il faut
toujours échanger et travailler ou la
préserver et concernant les défis
d'aujourd'hui comme par exemple la
pandémie du coc u19
comment pour vous c'est on diminue à
changer la donne dans les relations
internationales
vous savez on n'avait qu'à être ou 21
sept
l'homme n'avait qu'à prétendre
anticipées surtout ce domaine
scientifique
il faut avouer madame que veut on a tous
été surpris et la pandémie a montré que
nous étions tous fragiles le monde en
général et que nous l'ont fait et sans
attention mais la pandémie
au lieu de nous
de nous séparer jeunes et les acteurs de
la planète nous a approchés parce que
tout le monde s'est dit nous devons
trouver la parade à cette endémie pour
que quand tu as travaillé pour que
l'économie puisse continuer à
fonctionner et que l'espèce humaine
résiste à ceux à ce fléau
oui en commun de temps des différents
pays ont trouvé les vaccins c'est la
volonté de survie qui est le plus
important dans
dans cette affaire de pandémie à
coronavirus mais justement le problème
c'est que les vaccins ne sont pas
répartis d'une manière juste dans le
monde il ya les pays développés qui en
requérant ou beaucoup plus que des pays
sous développés et des pays en voie de
développement comme en ont peut-être
pourrait-on remédier à cette situation
oui ce qui me rassure moi ce qui rassure
les pédales on ne sait que ce problème
de du manque d'équité dans la
répartition des vaccins étaient abordés
au grand forum par exemple pour des
normands au g7
la question a été abordée au niveau de
l'union africaine nous des nations unies
de seclin général on a parlé je pense
que
ce message là est entendue et dans tous
les cas on peut abandonner afrique a
senti que ça à ce que les rats sains
tout simplement que nous comptions
fréquenté si l'afrique où les autres
parties du monde ne sont pas prises en
compte dans le cadre du vaccin mais il
ya une perturbation de l'économie
une partie du cash nations unies des
relations internationales du manioc par
exemple tous serré toutes ces réunions
que l'on fait en vidéoconférence c'est
parce qu'on peut rien faire
mais lorsque on se parle on se regarde
dans les yeux dans les yeux en sang ce
qu'est le partenaire on arrive à de
meilleures solutions
d'accord et justement si on parle des
héros bien on peut au sujet de la
sécurité quels sont les défis
sécuritaires auxquels votre répit
s'efface aujourd'hui les défis
sécuritaires sont nombreux mais on n'a
pas de données essentielle
le premier défi c'est d'abord
assurer la sécurité des personnes et des
biens pour que les comme monnaie sur le
territoire nous pensons qu'en 2000 m²
puisse aller et venir et entreprendre le
premier défi le deuxième défi c'est le
premier à la protection de nos
frontières
dans un monde où les flux migratoires
sont importants et les hordes de
terroristes certains le monde qui
viennent déstabiliser les états et font
que
nos fonctions des institutions soient
père tué un autre défi qui est
sécuritaire c'est tout ce qui est lié et
j'en ai parlé au cours de cette
conférence sans qu'elles soient liées à
la sécurité marty maritime savez nous
sommes un pays qui a une façade maritime
qui a une frontière avec un pays voisin
2009 100 km lorsque la mer est perturbé
comprenez madame que une grande partie
de l'économie vient de la mer vous avez
de quoi il s'agit donc pour nous les
routes maritimes d'eau vecteur doit être
protégé pour que notre port de pointe
noire peut se jouer son rôle de ports
majeurs en eaux profondes en afrique
centrale
ensuite
nous donner des filles aujourd'hui c'est
la maîtrise de la pandémie à virus a
couronné un virus parce que il nous faut
le
l'art si nos populations il nous faut
avoir la capacité de dépister de soigner
et donc
de préparer notre peuple a compris ceux
des films majeurs et quel est le rôle de
la communauté internationale dans devant
tous ces défis est ce que la communauté
internationale doit agir plus où on
votera dit mais madame le monde est le
même nous devons tous sur une planète
certains disent que c'est le village
commun donc sur la sécurité maritime
c'est l'économie vous bien que nous nous
échangions que nous obtenions sur la
pandémie
il faut bien regarder en face au nahd
pen joue son rôle pour soutenir les plus
faibles et
poursuivre la recherche sur ce virus qui
nous a tous surpris donc continuer à
dire qu' il est important que tous sous
le couvert des nations unies qui s'en
charge et de la paix dans le monde
sous le couvert de l'union africaine et
des communautés économiques régionales
que nous mettions ensemble pour faire
face à ces défis qui sont immenses jean
yves le drian quand il était à
brazzaville en octobre dernier il a dit
que l'afrique et la france doivent faire
face bloc ensemble face aux tentatives
de prédation est la rivalité des
puissances
donc il a plusieurs fois dénoncé à
plusieurs reprises dénoncé le rôle
croissant de la russie dans la région
comment voyez-vous justement cette
rivalité si on peut dire entre la russie
et la france
s'il existe à votre règne moi je ne je
ne pas pas de rivalité
depuis la fin de la guerre mondiale il a
réussi à jouer son rôle signifie qu'un
international les autres puissances
occidentales jouent leur rôle est ce qui
fait le charme du monde sait que on soit
tous ensemble et chaque pays grands ou
petits joue son rôle et vous sa
partition maintenant dans un partenariat
comme on dit gagnant gagnant il n'y a
pas de rivalité
chacun joue son rôle est justement non
la nature des relations aujourd'hui du
congo avec la russie donc comment voyez
vous les relations reçu retombe au laser
aujourd'hui comme celle au congo mais
nous n'avons plus de 50 ans de relations
diplomatiques
une cinquante ans du réseau culturel
plus de 50 ans de relation militaire et
technique nos relations sont au beau
fixe
et vous voyez bien que nous avons été
invités à cette conférence
je la sécurité internationales nous
arrivons à chaque à chaque session
nos relations sont bonnes parce que nous
avons atteint la même dépassé la
maturité un cadre de ses relations entre
pays amis et honteux pays qui ont un
passé commun
mais nous ne ne sont pas connues hier
matin mais ça fait longtemps maintenant
que deere notre présence ici c'est pour
marquer
l'excellence des relations entre la
russie et la fédération de russie et le
congo brazzaville
merci beaucoup je suis moi qui vous
remercie pour cette invitation
[Musique]
je